as all of you know I'm the second most
famous rapper associated with the daily
wire in recent weeks and I think I'm the
number one rap critic okay I am a
cultural Maven A hip-hop Guru and Tom
McDonald has a new song out so we're
going to take a look it's called sheeple
[Music]
the new and killing all the little guys
find out who you're not allowed to
criticize
whatever ever actual slaves fighting
with white folks who ain't actual Nazis
controlled by Rich folks who use the
news to make hate while Elite folks
control other political parties it's a
big lie trying to make you pick sides
trying to make you burn the cities down
and kill each other they got sick Minds
big lies keep on the police so that
there's big crime to take away our
freedom to restore order they Let Die
play with people you take a pause there
yeah so what he's alluding to there is
anarcho tyranny the idea that the ruling
establishment will actually encourage
lawlessness this would be what happened
in BLM or antifa or regularly seems to
happen in the United States and they do
that in order to clamp down yet again
and then he's talking as well about this
idea of a una party that yes there are
two political parties and it seems like
they're fighting each other we need the
Democrats to win no we need the
Republicans to win but but oddly enough
whichever party wins for some reason we
always get more and more immigrants
duration we always get more and more
Outsourcing of our jobs we always get
more and more of the weird
transgenderism occasionally some
pro-life laws in recent years that's
kind of come back but for a long time no
change even on abortion whichever party
wins it seems like it's kind of just a
puppet show it seems like it's theater
Because the actual political interests
that are that are forging our political
Community they actually are not all that
accountable to the elections and that's
what he's talking about and that's
pretty insightful
but Millions they starve you with a lack
of information and only give you facts
to a branded Corporation to start your
worldview with an algorithm that changes
based on propaganda curated for your
engagement we can't be free
[Applause]
this plug is going into his nose
[Music]
Is What It Seems
they trying to dumb you down they
endorse whatever narrative is popular to
shout and use minorities and movies for
diversity clout two sides on the
Spectrum but ain't none of them honest
took the red pill and the blue pill spit
them both in the garbage being woke used
to me and you understood your retarget
and now it's having two good legs and
never taking this step forward if you
agree it's free speech disagree it's
hate speech erase it if it came from
anywhere except the mainstream Trump
supporters labeled as the races but they
can't be Lincoln was Republican and
that's who ended slavery science been
politicized it's easy to see a mass
became a symbol of which side you
believe but you'll never cure a sickness
till you cure and agreed because the
problem with our natural immunity is
it's free Society is broken once you
locked inside a cubicle addicted to
pornography liquor and pharmaceuticals
hell yeah fat and poor and you were
never beautiful then tweet how much they
love you when they hear about your
funeral see see it just cuts across the
party lines we're saying yeah what they
want to do meaning the ruling
establishment regardless of Republican
or Democrat they want to keep you locked
to a cubicle addicted to pornography
pumped full of big Pharma drugs and
that's absolutely right and is that a
Democrat issue yeah the Democrats are
are for legalizing drugs but a lot of
the libertarian type Republicans are for
that too and a lot of the establishment
Republicans are in the pocket of big
farmer you look at porn yeah the libs
are pushing the weird sex stuff but a
lot of the Republicans have in at least
in recent decades said that there's some
you know Free Speech as American as
apple pie right to look at degrading
horrific porn that would have been
considered illegal for virtually all of
American history and it's actually still
probably according to the books illegal
today even though those laws have not
been enforced in about 14 years or so so
he's saying look look at what's actually
happening here folks you're off talking
about your pie in the sky ideological
fantasies okay what what's the reality
of your life you're chained to a cubicle
you're addicted to porn you get pumped
full of drugs you lose your political
Freedom literally masking you up and
that's a symbol of their political power
over you and half the time you're not
even aware of it because you've gone
numb looking at the stupid Hollywood
images that are intended to dumb you
down and it's just a kind of a theater
it's a kind of a show but the the ruling
establishment has a firm grip on power
it's a good point
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
they divided You by race religion
incoming sex made everybody right and
left the hatred got so intense if the
other side likes oxygen you'll put a bag
on your head and the conspiracy I
literally this information is just a
terrifying truth that scares the hell
out the nation the system treating you
like trash and you got rifles to aim
with just imagine how they'll treat you
when your guns get compensated George
Orwell 1984 was his last lecture George
called him top police now we call him
back Checkers government surveillance
trying to catch you they don't ask
questions mass incarceration equals
capital for cash investors the system
isn't broke it's working fine oppressive
and chaotic is how it was designed they
say if we ain't doing nothing wrong
there's nothing to hide while their
agenda and intelligence completely
classified they don't teach your rights
to school you never learn them at all
because they're easy to remove if you
don't know what they are the only people
you can rule are the criminal ones so
they force you in the corners till
you're breaking the law
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
all right their kids are keeping us
divided so we're saying we need to kind
of some way to get United it's not just
the Democrats versus the Republicans who
actually agree on probably more than
they disagree on then there's this kind
of third movement you see with the
populism kind of trump Maga movement
that is Reaching Across partisan lines
and you're seeing it at the racial level
you're seeing it geographically Trump
brought in a lot of new voters to the
GOP that that had not been associated
with the GOP in many many decades saying
we've got to unite because the the
forces that are keeping us down and
destroying our political community that
they're artificially dividing us it's a
very good point it's funny too because
it says the video by Nova Rockefeller
and when you think political
establishment you tend to think the
Rockefellers but probably that's
probably a different Rockefeller I dig
it I think it's great I think really the
only thing that could have improved the
song is a ukulele solo so I look forward
to the next Tom McDonald release until
next time I'm Michael Knowles
[Music]